it's great to be back at strange loop
again
under
slightly different circumstances but fun
nevertheless and
i'm really glad alex and all the
organizers were able to pull this off
that's fantastic i know it was very
challenging
um yeah so
since alex mentioned it yes i was on
japanese tv for ramen and i'll be on
japanese tv again for ramen soon
if you're interested i can give you more
details
okay so
listen i'm will i'm at the hugh call
precision medicine institute at the
university of alabama at birmingham and
these days i'm applying
functional programming relational
programming and all that but i'm not
going to talk about those things so so
we're applying
interesting programming language and
computer science technology some of
which is actually related to things i'll
talk about today
to precision medicine
and if you're interested in that i'm
happy to tell you about that
but i'm not going to talk about that
today i'm going to talk about sort of
lower level
issues that are
maybe more strange loopish i figure if
there's a strange loop keynote i should
talk about strange loop things
because
i work
on the government project i have to have
this disclaimer
basically the content is solely the
responsibility authors and does not
necessarily represent the official views
of the national institutes of health and
i believe that is accurate
my brother who is who's a medical
researcher just sent me this
it will remain unnamed where this came
from but let's just say it was a
government website and it was giving
information advice about writing a grant
proposal and it said
innovation if you are either a new pi
principal investigator or entering a new
area be cautious about seeming too
innovative
not only is innovation just one of the
five review criteria but there might be
a paradigm shift in your area of science
a reviewer may take a challenge to the
status quo as a challenge to his or her
world view
this may not represent the official view
of william byrd
this may represent the official view of
william byrd
okay and i'd like to thank
three people i'd like to thank my dad
i'd like to thank dan and i'd like to
thank doug so my dad dr edward byrd
really inspired my interest in the world
in the natural world and science and
things like that dan friedman
basically taught me everything i know
about computation that's worth
knowing and
doug hofstadter has been an inspiration
to me
since high school and
i was very fortunate that when i went to
graduate school at indiana i got to to
meet doug and get to know him
and dan actually hired doug
so they're they're good friends and so
i would like to
to dedicate this talk to
those three people
and i would also like to thank nada min
who is my partner in quine as you will
see
and
so so nada and i have been playing
around with parts of the code for this
talk
sort of got nerd sniped reading
doug's books and i nerd snipe not along
the way so thank you to nada as well
so
when i decided
to to think about this talk i wanted to
do something involving doug and strange
loops and so i started reading through
you know once again i bought copies of
all these books which i've read
at least part of
multiple times and i ordered more copies
so there's i am a strange loop
there's gurdwesh or bach
which is
like almost 800 pages
metamagical fema's which is
more than 800 pages which are doug's
collected articles from scientific
american
and i started reading through those
i was interested to find that i am a
strange loop that was not the original
title of the book
the original title of the book was i is
a strange loop
which doug decided was a bad title but
actually i think it was a terrific title
because it really gets into what what
that book's about and what's he's what
he is thinking about
um
and here's a little aside i wrote a book
with
uh dan friedman and oleg kessler of and
came out in 2005 called the reason
schemer and i wanted to call it the
reason schemer and doug want i mean dan
wanted to call it something else and the
tiebreaker was doug hofstetter and when
doug said reason schemer is better
became the reason schemer so thank you
to doug for that one
but i'm not going to talk about that
book
instead the things we're going to talk
about are more from geb and metamagical
themas
in terms of sort of the low level
content
the
the ideas in i am a strange loop which
which
match very
much with geb
those are very deep ideas
and
when reading those books
i ended up suffering i think from a very
bad case of udis which is unintended
doug intimidation syndrome
but if you try to read too much doug
hofstetter
it's hard to avoid this and there are
actually two types of this
type one
is you know doug is just a very
you know
cultured person he speaks he says he's
bilingual okay he speaks a little more
than three languages
and he knows all about music and all
sorts of things like that and so as i
was explaining to nada you know a little
intimidated
reading
up about choppin
and
she said that's not how it's pronounced
and i said well that's that's exactly my
point right
but
in my defense i probably know more than
doug does about the c electro breaks
remax of remix of shabayan records
monochrome in the night sung by 3l
that's probably the greatest song ever
created by the greatest singer who's
ever lived i think doug might disagree
with that but you should check it out it
might change your life
but anyway so so that's how i sort of
compensate for the type one
udis is okay so doug knows certain
things i'm passionate about other things
that's fine so i can get past the type 1
udis if i remind myself of that i mean i
don't know how much doug knows about
competitive starcraft for example
probably
less than i do
but the harder part to get past is udis
type 2
and uds udis type 2 is when you're
reading these books or having a
conversation with doug which i've had
been fortunate enough to
have lunch and dinner with him and
things like that
you know it's uh i mean he never does
this because he's such a
polite and
and pleasant person to talk to but if he
wanted to he could say
and what is your theory of mind and you
know what what is your theory of
consciousness and cognition that you've
been working on your whole life and and
i don't to be honest i don't really have
one so
it makes it you know
somewhat intimidating to think about
these very big pictures like what it is
what is it to be i
what is i um so forth and
you know i i
i was going to take a shot at
trying to come up my own theory of
cognition in the last two weeks but i
decided
uh to not do that
and
instead i was inspired by
a great talk that doug gave at stanford
which is available on youtube i really
recommend this
i'll put it online somewhere on my
website or something i'll put up a page
with all this
but he he told this very charming story
of danny at the grand canyon so his son
danny
a very very young age maybe not even a
toddler
doug's family and some family friends
took a trip to the grand canyon
and everyone's looking at this gigantic
majestic
landscape and and danny who's like one
year old
is uh sitting there not looking at the
grand canyon but rather fixated by ants
you know so he spent the whole trip
looking at ants on the ground
and people somehow thought that this was
um
interesting or unusual
that you know here you know he can look
at ants anywhere
but really my talks in defense of ants
in defense of looking at ants because i
think ants have a lot to teach us and
you know if the grand canyon is the
theory of mind and the theory of
cognition
and the theory of consciousness
you know it's fine to be thinking about
that and looking at that but maybe we
need to spend more time also looking at
the ants
and
i think that there are ants that are
involved in things like strange loops
and self-reference and and so forth that
doug talks about and and i'm going to
propose that quines
are the ants of strange loops so these
are tiny little things
that maybe look kind of boring at first
but once you start looking deeply
into them they have all sorts of secrets
and you can explore them
and so you know part of the question i
have had and you know not just for this
talk but since high school when i'm
trying to read something like geb
which is talking about issues of things
like consciousness and
cognition and the mind
how do you how do you get into that you
know i mean it's pretty tricky and there
are also things like
girdle
incompleteness theorems and all sorts of
things like that along the way which are
really really deep
and it's it's kind of hard to uh to
reach out and touch some of those things
certainly uh ideas of the mind in fact
doug as far as i can tell doesn't think
we'll ever be able to grasp
a full understanding of what it means
to to be conscious or to what eye is
that that's sort of beyond our reach
but it's still such a big scale it's the
grand canyon okay and and it's hard to
get into so instead
what i advocate is first of all i think
these ideas are important and extremely
interesting and fun and fascinating and
the way i
i think
is a reasonable way to engage these
ideas
is through constructive play
through trying to play around with
little parts sort of the ants
of the strange loop world
and and seeing how we can
build up intuition and try to find
surprising things
and so when i was in high school there
was a great program for the amiga 500 if
you remember that computer it was called
doug's math aquarium
and it was amazing it could draw
fractals and do all sorts of really cool
math exploration
and so i think that we need a different
doug we need like instead of a doug math
aquarium we need like a doug's quina
emporium or something like that okay so
we can we can really constructively
explore these little mini
uh strange loops and self-reference
behavior and self-reproduction behavior
sort of in the mathematical and
computational world which is
at least close to my heart and i think
close to the heart of many people
interested in computation and
programming and so forth programming
languages
and and i will modestly or immodestly
propose that one good way to
constructively explore these ideas are
through relational programming so that's
something i've been working on a long
time
with dan friedman and ole kislyoff and
now many other people nada michael
ballentine i mean the the list is
far too long for me to to give it
completely so i'll stop right there but
this idea of relational programming
which i'll show you in a minute
i think is a very interesting way to
explore some of the ideas now one one
reason is
you know the ideas that duggar is
interested in are tied up in things like
uncomputability or incompleteness
theorems and
just like scheme is the language for
learning recursion mini canrin which is
the relational programming language i
work on is the language for infinite
loops if you want to understand infinite
loops write some mini canon programs and
you will understand very quickly the
halting problem
um
you will you will
have your fingers singed by the halting
problem very quickly
but it's not just things like the
halting problem and in completeness
there's also all sorts of issues of
self-reference that come up in the
implementation of relational programming
and
more concretely or sort of more
interestingly in sort of a constructive
way which i'm going to show you
in a minute in particular we're going to
look at some quine oriented programming
and quap i guess you pronounce it
and we're gonna have some coin time as
dan friedman would say so let's
explore some coin time
all right
now
normally when i'm showing this i spend a
good 15 minutes introducing you to the
basic ideas of the mini canron language
and relational programs and so forth
i'm going to try to skip as much of that
as possible
and instead focus on sort of the the
main high level conceptual ideas which i
think you'll be able to get without me
getting into all the details language
what i can tell you is that the mini can
run language is very small
baseland has three core logical
operators one interface operator you
could write down all the operations of
the language on a three by five inch
index card very easily you could write
down the whole
api for language even with the
extensions there are a few extensions
that are sometimes useful
and the most interesting program
that we've written
is
what are called relational interpreters
so
let's see
well okay just to give
a little more hint maybe
let's see i will i will go ahead i think
i have time to show you this example if
you haven't seen it already this is
example you might have seen in prologue
if you've ever done any prologue
programmer programming and so let's see
if we can get this
we're going to write a little program
called appendo
and forget the syntax of this language
if you've never seen benny cameron it's
not so important
what's what i'm going to focus on
is the behavior
you know these programs might look a
little odd but they're not super long
you could figure it out if you wanted to
okay
and mini cameron the version i'm using
is embedded in scheme
let's see
a lot i could say about this particular
example but i'm not going to
all right i think we have it defined
and now i'm going to give you a simple
example so first of all let's just look
at
regular append in scheme
so in scheme we can append two lists so
i can say something like
i love the list list i love
uh in the list strange loop
and i can append those two lists
together to give me the list i love
strange loop okay i have two quoted
lists another basically data and i can
append those together and so now i have
this appendo
relation
notice it takes three arguments instead
of two
so we have two lists coming in and then
what you might consider an output list
and so now i can run
a little query
i could say
appendo so we use o
to say it's a relation sort of sounds
spanish or something but a pendo
i love
let me put in a new line
i love
strange
[Music]
okay and now i'm going to put in a third
argument
that third argument is q that's our
query variable so the run one means i
want one answer if it exists and i'm
going to try to fill in or have mini
canon fill in the value of q that will
make this true so what i'm asking is if
you append the list i love to the less
strange loop what list should you get
back
and we get the list i love strange loop
notice that list is itself
embedded in a list we'll see why in a
second okay so that's a very simple
example of a mini canron program or
relation
now let's try to make it a little more
interesting
because that's
you know you can already do that in
scheme if you want
but where it gets more interesting
is if we
go ahead
and say what the third argument should
be so we could say the third argument to
appendo should be the list i love
strange loop
and now i can put in q
the query variable in the middle
so now i'm asking
if i
take the list i love
and i append q onto it i get i love
strange loop so what is q
and now we see q is strange loop
and if we want to
get a little more fancy
i can say
how about we have two query variables x
and y so i want to find two lists x and
y that when appended together gives a
list
i love strange loop and we can see
there's one answer where x is the empty
list and y is a list i love strange loop
but we can ask for all of the answers we
could have done one two but here i'll do
a run star
and now we can see
all of the possibilities okay so
x can be any of these lists in the first
position y can be any less in the second
position
and
it turns out this is far more flexible
if we wanted to we could do things like
this
okay so i could say give me all the
lists x y and z such that x
and y
concatenated together give me z
i will not run this query for
for reasons that
if you need me to explain why i won't
run it talk to me after the talk you
know
i've got a book to recommend for you man
um
but anyway uh we can do a run one and
we'll see a very abstract answer so here
we have a very abstract answer saying if
x is the empty list and y is anything
then z is that one thing the same thing
so you notice with underscore dots that
represents
you know any sort of value whatsoever
and notice that the numbers the zeros
are the same in the y and z position
saying that hey it's actually the same
value
so that's the sort of thing you can get
in many cameras this is effectively a
theorem representing infinitely many
concrete values so from that sense you
can think of many cameras or like a
theorem prover or maybe a theorem
generator
okay so that's the simple version now
we're going to crank it up to 11. you
may have seen this if you took prologue
by the way or read something like the
art of prologue you may have seen
something like this but the difference
between what's done in the traditional
logic programming world something like
prologue and in mini caneron is that in
prolog once the programs start becoming
complicated
trying to make everything as a relation
where you can put logic variables
representing unknown values in any
position becomes hard so what people
tend to do
in in the prologue world is once the
programs become complicated enough
they sort of start using what are called
logical side effects or actual logical
operators and where you can't put in any
value you want in the x y and z position
so that's
where we're going to avoid that we're
going to stay purely logical
at all times and i won't tell you how it
works under the hood although that's
very interesting
there's a paper by dan friedman and
jason heyman uh jason heyman had done a
lot of work on something called
microcanron which shows you how to
implement the basic underlying search
and uh unification system so if you're
interested
you can implement your own version of a
simple mini camera and something like 50
lines of code
so it's worth trying
okay but i'm going to go ahead and show
you something more complicated and so
instead of something more simple instead
of appending tooth to list to get a
third list we're going to go ahead and
jump to an interpreter we're going to go
ahead and write an interpreter in mini
canron
so so the interpreter itself is a
relation and we'll see what that does so
so first of all something you should
know about scheme which maybe you've
already seen this in lisp or maybe
you've seen this in another language
in scheme there's a difference between
expressions that represent code ready to
be evaluated like plus 3 4 which
evaluates to 7
and quoted lists
are quoted datum
okay so all i have to do is put that
quote mark in front of the expression
plus 3 4 and instead of doing the
evaluation
and getting back 7 i instead get back a
list or a tree in general representing
the computation
so i just get back plus 3 4. so i have
data now what if i actually wanted to
evaluate that data well in scheme
there's a function called a vowel so i
can actually take the quoted data
and feed it to this eval function and
valve
is basically the little interpreter for
scheme
and then
i get back seven okay so we can play
this game between quoting and evaluation
if you read gurdwash or bach and you
read metamagical themes you see how
critical this is
to issues of self-reference
issues of code versus data you see the
same sort of behavior
in molecular biology
with dna representation
where dna basically gets turned into
messenger rna which goes through
ribosome and and through the ribosome
you get proteins which are the robots
and that they the the proteins
themselves can reproduce the dna and
things like that so that's a type of
strange loop and this idea of code
versus data or procedures
processes versus data is really at the
heart of many of these strange loops and
many of these processes including the
processes that are happening in every
cell of your body every second of the
day
which
is
at the heart of how life works
so this is a very
important idea and doug talks about it
at length including making lots of
connections between molecular biology
anyway this idea of quoting
we'll see in a minute
so we have a vowel which is the standard
scheme evaluator which is an interpreter
and takes a quoted expression and it
evaluates that
great now
we're going to take
our
vowel and we're going to rewrite our own
a vowel called a valo
sort of like a pendo instead of a pen
and that evalo will be an interpreter
which behaves as a relation so instead
of the functioning vowel which takes one
expression
and produces a value we will have a two
place evaluator called valo
that takes an expression and a value
so let's go ahead and try it i think i
reloaded it let's see
yes there great that's always the
hardest part is do i load the right file
okay so let's try this
i'm going to call evalo which i've
already written
and if you've written an environment
passing interpreter for scheme like a
meta circular interpreter evalo is
actually not that
not that tricky to write in many can run
in fact you could argue that mini canron
at this point is basically a language
optimized for writing a valo that's not
too far
i mean it's kind of true
but that's because evaluators are super
important okay
so
we're going to go ahead and
have a little quoted expression how
about quote i
quote love
all right
i'll say strange
loop
all right so we are evaluating this
quoted expression list and scheme just
creates a list of arguments so we have
quote i quote love quotes oh i need to
put quote in front of strange and
loop okay so we just have a list of
quoted symbols that we're putting
together and if i run that i get
a list containing the list i love
strange loop all right that's not very
interesting
just to show you that this is
the real deal if i take the unquoted
expression and just run it in scheme i
get back the same list okay i don't get
a list of lists because we're only
getting one answer back in chase game
but it's the same idea now let's go the
other way i will take the list i love
strange lube
and i will put that in the value
position instead of in the expression
position
and so let me write this expression this
query so here i'm saying i want an
expression in the subset of scheme i've
implemented that evaluates to the list i
love strange loop i want one such
expression if it exists let me try it
okay i get quote the list i love strange
loop which is true
but not very exciting so let's try doing
99
okay this is maybe more interesting
okay so here's
here let me grab one now there are some
side conditions down below i'll ignore
for now
and this is a little hard to read so if
i wanted to
these underscore zeros and underscore
ones and underscore twos represent sort
of abstract values because this is
really a theorem but you can see there's
a called list with no arguments which
produces the empty list we have a
function call here we have a lambda this
is effectively a let expression
and so i run that and sure enough in
shea scheme it produces i love strange
loop so we can start playing these games
all right
now
the
next expression
the next
parlor trick we're going to play
is what if we wanted to generate
an expression in scheme or a subset of
scheme
that evaluates to itself
what would that query look like
we want an expression that evaluates
itself yes
avalo ee it can't possibly be that
simple
and yet it is once again
okay so let's grab this
and
i will run it and we get back
the same expression and if i change the
let's see if i can do this if i change
the underscore 0 to x
all right just to make it a little
easier i'm making
i'm basically instantiating the variable
name
then that is sort of the canonical quine
for
lisp or or scheme
okay so so i used the word quine so this
is a program that evaluates to itself
which doug hofstetter in geb coins as a
quine after the mathematician quine and
notice the use of quote
notice the use of evaluation and the use
of quote very important and
as doug points out this is similar in a
way
to what's going on at the molecular
biology level and so forth and we've got
strange loop-ish behavior starting to
become manifest
okay
let's try doing something
a little more aggressive
so that is equine this is an expression
that generates a quine let's generate
twines
so twines are twin primes
okay so
twin primes or primes p and q
are equines p and q such that p
evaluates the q and q evaluates to p and
they're distinct
okay so let me try to write that
so we have p and q
you p evaluate to q
q evaluate to p
all right so is that
is that the right query
or do we need to add something else
okay we need to say they're distinct
right and so this is the version i've
been showing for a number of years now
ever since
basically ever since stu holloway
pointed out
to me and to dan that we should be able
to generate coins i've been doing this
version where i say
p is not equal to q okay and sure enough
we can
generate
two distinct programs
but
these programs are actually kind of
boring okay as a reviewer pointed out in
one paper this is kind of boring because
one version is just a quoted expression
and it evaluates to the unquoted version
of itself
and then if you evaluate the unquoted
version whoops hold on a second if you
evaluate the unquoted version you just
get back the quoted version so it's like
you know basically we're just
adding or removing the quote
from the beginning
now
when i was starting to read these books
again in preparation for this talk
i got interested in aquines because doug
was talking about the quines in this
book
and it
occurred to me to try
something a little bit different
which is to use another constraint that
we have in mini cameron called obsento
which is saying that the first term
cannot appear anywhere within the second
term
okay and so now we're saying p and q not
only do they have to be distinct but p
structurally can't appear in sud q or
vice versa and now when i run it i start
getting twines that are actually
structurally different so
here
i've got equine where i'm calling lists
on the outside you can see there's a
bunch of quoted stuff going on and when
i run it
i get a direct application of a lambda
expression and when i run that i get my
call to list again and so we can start
playing new games here and this was
interesting to me because i guess i've
been
you know doing demos of the quine stuff
in minnie canron for
10 years something like that
maybe longer and i just finally realized
that
there's this trivial change that makes
the quines much more interesting
nada and i have been playing around
quite a bit with a whole bunch of
different versions of quine so one
version we have is the quine relay
which
let's see i might be able to show you
that quickly let's
well
um
okay i'll show you the coin relay real
quick
i actually have lots and lots of things
i could show you
i've got a lot of coins i could show you
but i'm not going to show them all to
you right now
we will
nada and i i think will post a live code
for for playing with the quines
but let's
see if we can load the coin relay
okay
all right so the way the quine relay
works
so this is an exploration
of
a simple program a simple ver a simple
version basically of something i saw a
few years ago that's much more
complicated and so the idea here
is that we now have three different
interpreters for different languages now
in in industrial climate relays you
might have code produced in you know a
python program that produces java
program a java program that produces c
plus program and so forth and eventually
it goes back and produces
the original python program you can keep
doing that okay so i wanted to to play
around with that the interesting thing
to me
was being able to synthesize the quines
automatically
by just giving the operational semantics
for the underlying language okay so
we're not constructing this by hand at
all we're just asking mini canron to
produce the quines or produce the code
by synthesis
just from the constraints we're writing
down and so for example in this version
i have an evaluator that uses cons
list constructor i have another
evaluator that has the list operator but
not cons
and then i have another one
that uses quasi quote instead of
list or
or cons so these are three different
ways of producing
of producing coins or sorry of producing
expressions
and
let's see if i can
um
let's see if i can find the
three
okay so here we have it
let's see if i can run it supposedly it
takes 36 seconds to finish so while it's
running let me try to explain so
um basically you've got three different
interpreters for three slightly
different versions of scheme and they're
different in the in the list operations
they handle so they're not as different
as as python and java but hopefully you
sort of get the point that we have three
different interpreters that are have
different languages and so
the eval quasi has quasi quote operator
if you're familiar with that but it
doesn't have cons or lists and then cons
kanzo and listo have cons and list
operators but not the other operators
and so now here we have
a
little coin relay program so if i can
find the start of it let's see here we
go
so the first one
let me make sure i'm running this
correctly
okay so the first
piece of code we have is quasi-quoted so
that's the back quote or quasi quote so
this is almost
constant data and if i run that
then i get another
expression that uses cons but without
the quasi quote and if i run that then i
get another expression which makes use
of list but which doesn't make use of
quasi quote or con so now we're getting
into
much more sophisticated behavior
self-reproducing behavior and the
interesting thing to me is that this is
all based on
encoding and operational semantics for
the underlying language as an
interpreter and then having a constraint
system
with search
and various types of constraint solving
to automatically figure out what the
behavior is okay so this is what i mean
by a constructive way to play around
with these ideas with quotation
interpreters equine self-reproduci
reproduction and so forth
nada and i have a whole bunch of
examples also
with
more sophisticated self-reproducing
reproduction sort of like the von
neumann
self-repo reproducing machines universal
constructor type programs and
various types of virus behavior that
doug talked about in his books but i
don't really want to show any virus
stuff this year so that's not i will put
that online but i'm not going to talk
about it
okay
so
i could show you a lot more quinish and
self-rep reproducing behavior
but let me make some strong claims now
so this reminds me of the danny at the
grand canyon story and if you take that
story seriously and you think about
what's going on with those ants
danny's looking at one ant by the grand
canyon that ant has a bunch of cells in
it in the gut
of the ant there are other types of
cells which aren't you know what we
might think of ant cells but they're
cells of
bacteria in the gut of the ant and
inside that bacterium in the gut of the
ant is a constant war between viruses
and other sort of bacteria which are
trying to exchange genetic material
with say an e coli
and one of the amazing things is if you
look closely enough you'll see
in the bacterium and
many species of bacterium
that have a circular genome
that there are these clustered regularly
interspersed palindromic repeat areas
of the genome
of the dna sequences
and it took a long time for people to
figure out what those are
well what those are are
databases that are dynamically updated
that contain basically dna snippets from
previous attempts at viral infection or
from other bacteria trying to
exchange genetic information and it's
actually
a defense mechanism against viral
infection so maybe you've heard of
crispr cass9 so cas9 cass is crispr
associated cass is cas9 is one of the
proteins
produced as part of this crispr defense
mechanisms there are other proteins or
two proteins that we know of at least
that actively maintain
this crispr database of genetic
sequences of viral from viral infections
attempted viral infections and there's
actually a fifo cue the first in first
out cue that gets actively maintained
in the genome
of a bacterium
and it turns out that
even though we aren't bacteria and we
aren't viruses
this mechanism
this crispr mechanism which is very
powerful can be used to modify dna
and as you may have heard
now can be mono used to modify dna in
humans and their ongoing clinical trials
in humans to try to fix up
problems with dna genetic based
diseases in humans in fact that the you
call precision medicine in suit this is
very relevant to what we're doing so
when you have danny at the grand canyon
staring at an ant if you zoom in enough
you've seen the same cellular processes
that are happening in danny
and if you zoom in even further
you see
this crisper defense mechanism
which
can now be used to treat humans and so
it turns out that danny i think was
right to look at the ant after all
similarly i think with behavior like
quines and in small self-reproducing
programs there are a lot of very
interesting things that if we uncover
them i think will have bigger
implications so
i would like to
defend uh tas which is taking ant
seriously and you think of the ant
industrial complex or well like i like
to call it big ant
and quines are the ants of strange loops
so we should think about taking quine
seriously and i mean really seriously
and so big quine quine industrial
complex and if you've heard of mips
which is either millions of instructions
per second or meaningless information
about processor speed or lips which is
logical inferences per second i propose
that we have a new measure which is
quips which are coins per second
and so we could have quite well
maybe not quinecoin that might be a bad
idea but we could have an x equip
supercomputer
and uh if we want to reach the stars
like in starcraft if we want to meet
meet the taldarim and get their
terrazine gas or whatever or if we want
a theory of consciousness then we really
need to get very very good at
understanding these very small strange
loops
that are at the heart of things like
quines or
viruses or self-reproducing behavior
and as as teller the magician says
sometimes magic is just someone spending
more time on something than anyone else
might reasonably expect i think we need
to spend unreasonable amounts of time
studying twines i don't think that's
currently being done so i'm going to
propose
i'm actually going to start the quips
prize so i will give a thousand dollars
a year from now to the best uh type of
self-reproduce reproducing behavior in
this constructive manner uh and if alex
allows me i'll even produce a i'll award
it at strange loop
and and so that's the web page i haven't
yet put up the
exact rules because i need to figure
those out um
and and so this is the very small
strange loops okay and i think we need
to take them very seriously uh there's
one other thing i want to talk about
which i didn't have time to prepare for
because i think this is going to be a
much bigger effort
is
john doyle who got his phd at the mit
artificial intelligence lab i think in
the early 80s has some amazing work
one is on truth maintenance systems
argumentative tmss that are
communicating with each other and then
his phd thesis proposal was on
communicating reflective metacircular
interpreters
and so these are like
bigger
bigger strange loops
and i i would say these are bigger ants
these are big ants
and in fact they're so big that
i'll call him mance which is from there
was a great movie called uh um matinee
with john goodman where it's about the
1950s horror movies and he he plays in a
movie called mant
half man half aunt all terror man is he
man or aunt so
i think this is like the mant
of of strange loops it's not not not
quite the small ant but it's the the
bigger ant so they'll also be a thousand
dollar man prize for
the the best implementation or
riffing on
one of these ideas in particular i think
the communicating reflective
meta-circular interpreters
is extremely important and something
very interesting happened after he
proposed this work
which is nothing
nothing happened
as far as i can tell and i i as far as i
can tell
literally no one in the world is
following up on these ideas this is
probably the best idea that i've ever
seen
having to do with strange loops and
things like that in the small and i
think there's a lot to be learned and
john doyle was going full steam
with these approaches towards real
artificial intelligence and
one of the things that happens over time
is that sort of people either lose their
nerve or they think it's too hard so
some of these techniques have sort of
made their way into programming lore but
removed from the idea of doing
artificial intelligence and much more
about you know here's a useful technique
for programmers but if you go back and
read the original works by doyle he was
trying to
basically build strong ai and even
though i don't know that you could get
there from here i think there's some
very powerful ideas that are extremely
underexplored
and uh you know are worth worthy of
exploration
so two prizes the man prize
and uh the quips prize
for one year from now i i will update my
web pages with the actual
rules and a thousand dollars each and if
alex allows i'll award them at uh
strange loop next year and so we should
take our aunt seriously we should take
our man seriously
and uh
you know respect the ant respect the
quine
and
get to it
all right thank you
i can't wait to see the respect the
quine t-shirt i'm ready for that one
i would be happy to have you announce
surprise next year great
that would be my pleasure
all right
and just just to remind you
does not officially it does not
necessarily represent the official views
of national institutes of health
it's probably good to note that
uh you said you haven't figured out the
rules yet have you considered using mini
camera
okay so i don't have the rules for
either the man or the quips
prize the competition and so the
question is had i considered using mini
canron to generate the rules
no i hadn't but that's a very
interesting idea and
one of the things doug talks about
in metamagical themes
is this idea of
a set of rules
for a game that are meant to be
modified or mutated right and i've
thought about encoding that in mini
canon and i suppose that could be
something that would also the prize
rules are expressed in minicandron and
they're mutating so every year
we get some sort of random mutation that
hopefully is survival the fittest but
maybe survival the fittest for my wallet
where i don't have to pay out a thousand
dollars for each prize
so you know i noticed in the um
in the mini can run demo of you know
just sort of doing code synthesis
um you know it can generate obviously
code for fixed outputs
um do you see any way of like
generalizing that so that you could just
have a constraint over the types of
outputs
oh for the title using type constraints
type constraints or anything similar to
logical constraints so so i mean i
normally show a lot more of that and so
we've got a tool called parliament that
i've been working on with greg
rosenblatt and also
michael ballentine and other people have
been helping us work on it and now i'm
working with uh kanaya tushima
in japan on sort of a new version of it
and
and so that's a synthesis system
designed to actually sort of be
efficient enough where you can you can
synthesize a sort of interesting
recursive definition from examples but
one of the ideas we want to have is to
also have things like type information
so you can the way it actually started
is before this relational interpreter
there was actually a relational type
inferencer and that was something that
oleg kislyak was working on and that was
there was the first mini cameron program
or actually back then it was cameron
that was the one that sort of blew my
mind and then i got obsessed with doing
the same thing with an interpreter and
it turned out
for various reasons doing it for an
interpreter was
maybe much trickier
so
what i would like to be able to do at
some point is have a synthesis system
that combines type information
other types of constraints like maybe
you could say i want to synthesize a
function
that is associative or commutative or
things like that and also give examples
uh and maybe several other types of
pieces of information and then maybe
give hints to uh the search and things
like that and also templates and so some
of these things we're actively working
on we're working on biasing the search
based on
on what
human written code looks like in scheme
and also doing probabilistic versions
and
templated queries and so forth so that
that's an active area of research
program census in general has become a
very active
area of research and
sort of formal methods and programming
languages it's been a lot of work some
of it is you know based on things like
dependent types and so forth
you know the approach we're taking is
somewhat different and
once again
i'm interested in the emergent behavior
when you just write down
uh the system of rules what can you get
out of it so you know the thing that i
want to preserve is the fact that we
don't have a synthesis system it's just
we're writing rules down and we have a
system that
that can uh that can be flexible enough
that you sort of get as an emergent
property
uh sort of is inherent in the rules but
we're not setting out to write a
synthesis system per se that's that's
what i'd like to
and that's also what's interesting to me
about the client stuff is that you know
nowhere encoded in any of that software
or that interpreter is the notion of
quines that came out of it in fact when
stu holloway said
at the closure conju that you should be
able to synthesize quines i was like oh
dan and i'm like oh yeah that's right
and then i was giving a talk at indiana
and larry moss i think it was said oh
you should be i'll do twines and i made
the joke okay i wrote the twine query
down i said you know i started it
running i said no one can leave until it
comes back i assumed it would take a
million years and then it came back
after like three seconds and it was kind
of
flabbergasted right so so that's the fun
thing to me this is what i mean by the
constructive exploration
the the fun part of it is like i can't
wrap my head around
you know i is a strange loop directly
that's like too big
but i can play around with the smaller
ideas and maybe there's something there
sort of like crispr that's useful i mean
there certainly are things
with quines like the smn theorem and you
know cleaning's recursion theorem and
somalians double recursion theorem
they're they're very important
computational ideas that are used in
bootstrapping compilers and that turn
out to be used in computer viruses and
things like that so these ideas are very
powerful but i think that there's a lot
more to to learn from exploring them
all right thanks everybody i'm i assume
that uh uh i assume that since nobody
has burst in with guns or anything like
that that
the this quine challenge doesn't lead to
the singularity and they have to send
people back through time to kill us so
but
thank you everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you